our home was destroyed an explosion blew
up the windows doors and everything all
the people who lived in the building ran
to the basement we moved to another part
of the city to find a friend's house but
the bombardments continued even there
the russian tanks kept firing at our
houses our priority now is a hotline
it's european it's uh
bucha it's a warzone it's a ghost storm
and this line okay and
actually they are
really shocked by all these things that
happening uh they didn't expect the
russian army to hit civilians to hit the
civilian houses and they never believed
it but they really under fire and our
checks this is destroyed completely
destroyed houses
many people's killed it is hard it's
hard to leave my hometown under fire i
cannot speak we will return we know that
we will return we believe we will return
soon it's very scary there we slept in
the basement with the children
constantly in the basement or cellar
shots non-stop we came to keeve and
we'll get used to the fact that it's
quiet here constantly quiet
children are crying all the time the
situation with food was difficult a lot
of corpses of locals just lying in the
streets